Look, Joey,
I'm a drummer, too.
[ Drumming ]
Taught one guy
everything he knows.
What is going on
with those two?
I have no idea.
[ Laughs ]
I have no [bleep] idea.
Well, let's smoke and maybe
get some clarity because...
The wolfman taught
the other kid.
He lent him the truck.
He wants $1,800.
I heard enough.
Yeah, he has friends.
I guess they stole
all of his stuff,
like they knew
he'd get messed up.
I just don't think
he has a strong case.
But I don't --
You know, I don't think
the other guy
is completely innocent
'cause why would he give
his truck to this dude?
The kid was in San Diego.
He went out, he got [bleep] up.
He gets what he deserves.
They gave him a Cosby pill
in Tijuana
and he woke up
with nothing.
That's what happens.
Next time,
you pay attention.
Loaning your truck
to a werewolf.
Can you imagine the road rage
those werewolves have
when they're out driving?
He's like
a [bleep] nightwalker.
He'll lose his car,
for sure.
But it sounds like the guy
admits that he had the car,
so the law
would say that...
9/10.
...he owes for the car.
But the car
is not worth...
$1,800.
...1,800 bucks.
Let's give him $250.
[Bleep] 'em.
[ Laughs ]
$250 and the buckets.
He's got enough.
Let him [bleep] go out and play
the drums till next week.
Well, whatever we give him,
we definitely have
to crumple it up
and throw it into his buckets.